おはようございま～すぅ～
朝、6時半ぐらいで～す
眠い
もう沖縄何回か来たことあるんですけども、
さっき泊まった場所が、
なんか、貸し、貸し民家っていうんですか？
ホテルとかじゃなくて、
民家、昔、人が住んでた古民家をこう綺麗に、
リノベーションって言うのかな？
うい！？
人生終わったと思った（汗
リノベーションというか、リフォームっていうか、綺麗にして
そこに人を住ませるってやつにちょっと住んだんですけども、
住んだというか、泊まったというかなんか、第一号だったらしくて
めちゃくちゃ綺麗な家ですごい住みやすかったっス
はいというわけで沖縄に来ております
まぁ見ての通りなんですけどね
あっ！
こんな犬見たことないぜ！（※ヤギです
犬！
いぬぅぅぅぅ～～～！！
犬！！
（指パッチン）
（舌打ち）
ふん。
凄くね？いr今いる場所
島だよ？島！
凄い所にいるなぁ今
なんか今日は完全にもう、
沖縄端っこというかちょっと外れの部分に来てるみたいなんで、凄い大自然が広がっておりますわぁ～！
とりあえずもうすぐ行くとですね、海が見えてくるんで、そこまでダッシュしようと思います！では！！
（謎の変顔）
白いなぁ～！砂が
はい！というわけで、ちょっとあいにくの曇りなんですけども、
なんか動画的には曇りのほうが顔が曇んないからいいんですって！
多分動画撮るには一番良い天気だと思われま～す！
そして、たくさんの忘れ物で～す
う゛わﾞあﾞあﾞあﾞあﾞあﾞあﾞあﾞ！！！！
た：びっくりした～（汗
は：おはよう
た：ア〇ル
は：おいおい！
は：洞窟だ！
た：うぉっ！？
た：おぉヤバイ！！
た：えっ！？
は：ヤバイヤバイヤバイ！！
た：ガチ、ガチっすよこれ！
は：うわ！スゴい！！
は：これって入っていいんですかね？
た：すげぇ！！
は：たてめん閉じ込めてえ～
た：やあ～めてくだせええ～
は：スゴい！
た：うわスゴい！なんか、
た：ホントにスゴい！
は：いや怖い！ヤヤヤバイよ！
は：蛇出てきたらどうする？
た：いやもうマムシぐらいしか出てこないっス
は：蛇出てきたらどうしよう
は：たてめん先に行きなさい！
た：はい分かりました！
た：え？どこまでっスか？
は：もうもうずっとずっと！
た：ずっとスか
た：もうマジでずっと続いてますよ？
は：行くよ？
た：行きましょう！
は：え！？
は：うわ待って！
は：ガチじゃん！
は：怖！！
は：え？
は：閉所恐怖症なんスよね～
は：ジャンケンで負けたら行こう！
た：OKっス！
2人：最初はグー、ジャンケンポイ！
は：はい
た：やっぱ俺か～（小声
た：へぇ～スゴい！わぁ～そうなってるんだ～！
は：待って！？え？そんなに行ける！？
た：あー！！
た：スゴい！
は：何？
た：スゴいこれ！！
は：もうちょっと分かりやすい説明を求む！
た：むちゃくちゃ虫がいます！
～ED～
は：オイ！
は：あんちゃんどっから来たんじゃ！？
は：オメェ！オイ！オイ！
た：wwwww
は：オメェに聞いとんじゃオイ！オイ！
は：オイ！オメェどっから来たんじゃ！？
た：静岡から来ました
は：あぁ静岡？
は：シャレたところから来よってオマエホンマァ！
は：オォ！
た：お兄さんどっから来たスか？
は：俺はこの島の者や！
た：あ、そうなんすか！
は：オォ！
た：ウォエ！？